this is a bit of raised ground to the
east of harkeve where the russians try
to use a tree line to give their one of
their armored columns some protection
and cover
in vain as it turns out because along
the stretch of land there is just one
wrecked russian tank or piece of heavy
armor after another but before that
happened the ukrainians say the russians
used these positions to carry out war
crimes they shelled the villages below
and they also shelled civilian vehicles
trying to bring aid to
the villages so we've been out this
morning filming ukrainian and lithuanian
investigators combing this land going
through the foxholes and camps and the
and the wrecked armor looking for any
evidence looking for names of soldiers
looking for documents anything that
links these soldiers with what they say
were war crimes and then they're going
to link that with what they found in the
villages below so early this week we
filmed a body being exumed he was a man
who had been out feeding his animals
when the russians shelled his home
killing him outright and his poor wife
had to bury him on her own so he's been
exhumed as part of this investigation
because
the facts of the rules of war mean that
anyone who is found guilty of attacking
civilians deliberately without any
military justification
is guilty of a war crime and this is
part of a much broader investigation
across all the land the ukrainians are
reclaiming from the russians
trying to prove that the invaders
carried out atrocities and the
investigator we spoke to says he's
confident
that the russians who they are building
evidence against here will eventually be
brought to justice